did you think he is incompetent insane
or evil
if you were to bet
money on each of those incompetent
insane or evil insane meaning he's lying
to everyone but also to himself
uh which you could which is a little bit
different than incompetence he's not
incompetent
so the I think he's some combination of
insane and evil but it's impossible to
know unless we know deep inside his
heart how self
like deluded he is versus a calculated
strategy and I think if you look at SBF
he's such a I think he's a fascinating
individual just I mean you know he's a
horrible human being let's start there
but he's also somewhat
um
interesting from a psychology
perspective because he's very open about
the fact that he understands image and
he understands how to cultivate image
the importance of image so well that I
think a lot of people even though
they've talked about it aren't
emphasizing that enough
when interacting with him this is a man
whose entire history is about
cultivating the right opinions at the
right time to achieve the right effect
why do you think he would suddenly
change that approach when he has all the
more reason to cultivate an image so he
is
extremely good naturally or uh I don't
know if he's good but he's like he's a
hyper aware he was deliberate in
cultivating a Public Image and
controlling the Public Image you you
know about the like Democrat donations
like he he knew to donate to the right
people 40 million dollars he says on a
call that we released with Tiffany Fong
he says on a call that he donated the
same amount to Republicans there's
speculation on whether this is true
because he's a liar whatever so caveat
there but he said he donated to
Republicans the same amount but he
donated dark because he knew that most
journalists are liberal and they would
kind of hold that against him so he
wanted all the all the sides to be on in
his favor in his pocket while
simultaneously understanding the entire
media landscape and playing them like a
fiddle by cultivating this image of I'm
this Progressive woke billionaire who
wants to give it all away do everything
for charity I drive a Corolla while
living in a million dollar Penthouse
multi-million
um but but that was sort of the angle he
he understood so well how to play the
media and um
I do I think he underestimated when he
did this how much people would put him
under a deeper microscope and I don't
think he has achieved the same level of
success in cultivating this new image
because I think people are so skeptical
now no one's buying it but I think he
he's trying it he's doing it to the best
but it has work leading up to this
particular wobbly situation so before
that was in their public perception of
him being
a Force for good a financial 100 yeah
somebody from Sequoia Capital you know
wrote this glowing review that he's
going to be the world's first
trillionaire there's so many pieces done
on he's the most generous billionaire in
the world that um he was sort of like
the Steel Man of you know it's possible
to make tons of money this is like the
effect of altruism movement make as much
money as you can as fast as you can and
give it all away and he was sort of like
the the poster child for that and he did
give some of it away and got a lot of
press for it and I think that was kind
of by Design I want to address a real
quick Point yes a lot of people have
said that like binance played a role and
while they catalyzed this
insolvency
is a problem that will eventually
manifest either way so I don't put any
blame on CZ for basically causing this
meltdown the the underlying Foundation
was unstable and it was going to fall
apart at the next push I mean he just
happened to be the final kind of like
uh I don't know the straw that broke the
camel's back yeah the Catalyst are
revealed yeah but he's like I don't I
don't think he's culpable for ftx's like
malfeasance and how they handle accounts
if that makes sense so what what role
did they play could they have helped
alleviate some of the pain of uh
uh investors of people that held funds
there yeah I mean
probably uh I don't know I I would see
some kind of weird obligation like with
the 2 billion they made on FTX remember
they got 2 billion some of it in cash
some of it in some of it in FDT token so
I don't know how much actual cash they
have from that deal but they have
billions from the success of what seems
to be a fraud seems to have been a fraud
from early on they had the back door as
early as 20 early 2020 from what I can
tell so the the back door between FTX
and um
uh do you think CZ saw through who SPF
is
what is he's doing
no I think
I think CZ is like he's a shark I think
he's he's good at building a big
business
um like a good I don't go back truck I
don't know I don't know I think sharks
just eat I mean I I don't I don't know I
think uh my relationship with Shaw has
like Finding Nemo there's a shark in
that sure I don't know I think like Jeff
Bezos is a shark okay so whether you
people have loaded connotations of like
how they feel about Jeff Bezos I mean I
I would say like I think CZ is a
ruthless businessman
I think these qualities calculated he's
very
um
deliberate and
I think uh what he should do in this
position is forfeit the funds that he
profited from that investment because
largely I think it was
um it's owed to the customers there's so
much hurting out there so I think I
think they could do a lot of good around
that
um I don't know if they will because I
don't know if he sees it in his best
interest I think that's probably how
he's thinking but yeah I I think they
could have helped or they could still
help there